hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from the uh well sort of the
final round it's round seven of this
year's Champions Chester finals it is
Maxim VRA versus NRE abdad and this is
their Armageddon game so their rapid
match ended in a draw and now it's time
to see who takes Armageddon of course
for those of you who are new to chess in
Armageddon you have to win with the
white pieces otherwise you lose the
match uh but you do get more time and
here they have a different uh system on
who gets the black pieces who gets the
white pieces you have to bid your time
and whoever wins starts with less time
on the clock so here Maxim opened with
Pawn to E4 uh and Notre backck replied
with Pawn to E5 and as you can see Notre
backck already down to 10 minutes and 29
seconds Maxim with the full 15 minutes
okay it's going to be a fairly
theoretical struggle in the opening
Knight C6 Bishop to B5 it's the Lopez uh
A6 morphe's defense Bishop to A4 and now
Knight to F6 we have castles and Bishop
to E7 so a very standard stuff the close
R Lopez Rook to E1 Pawn to B5 Bishop to
B3 and now D6 uh we have Pawn to C3 and
now we have castles uh Pawn to H3 uh and
the most popular way uh to handle this
is just to move the Knight and then
Advance the pawn to C5 sometimes this is
achieved by moving the Knight to A5 uh
sometimes by going for Knight to B8 also
known as the Brer defense of the R Lopez
H we have Pawn to D4 and you can't
strike in the center with C5 now because
now uh Black's E5 Pawn is hanging so you
have to defend it first Knight bd7 and
now uh well usually Knight B to D2 is
played but here we have Pawn to C4 and
it's a much less played line than the
Knight B to D2 line Hikaru even employed
it once against Magnus cross and they
they drew their game and also I think
someone else employed it against Magnus
but they they lost that one uh okay
Bishop to B7 putting more pressure on
that E4 pawn and Knight to C3 defending
we have Pawn to B4 now chasing away the
Knight and if you don't want to lose the
pawn you have to bring the Knight to D5
which is what Max team does uh Pawn to
A5 trying to uh kick away the B with
Pawn to A4 so Pawn to A3 and C6 now
chasing away the Knight Knight captures
on E7 we have Queen captures and now
there is a game uh that was played in
2018 um vas dur played against s lvas
suran and he won a very nice game by
going Knight to H4 the idea is you want
to go to F5 and then for example Knight
H4 you block this you don't allow Knight
here but then you allow Bishop to H6
then black has to waste a move with the
rook and white got a very nice position
however here Maxim rushed a little bit
he didn't go for this plan which is in
fact the the strongest plan recommended
by the engine he went for the trade
right away and now it's a little bit
different because now after a captures
on B4 and the trade on A8 you don't have
to do all of this like I mentioned
wasting a move with the Rook you
immediately get the Rook over to the a
file so it's a little bit better for for
uh black as white was not all that
precise and here we have Pawn to C5 uh
which puts more pressure on that E5 pawn
and it's a pawn sacrifice but um you
will have to prove that that it's a pawn
sacrifice that works D captures on C5 D
captures on E5 Knight captures Knight
captures and queen captures and here
Maxim just plays Queen to C2 he's down a
pawn but Notre Beck does have the Double
T pawn and uh it will be a weakness
later on and another thing uh if you
don't move the pawns then this bishop
will not be a very useful piece on this
diagonal so all in all Maxim does have
compensation for the PA Pawn we have
Bishop to A6 and now Pawn to F4 chasing
away another back's queen queen to E7
and now King to H2 now preparing the
further pushed pawns with Pawn to E5 and
pawn to E6 as he does have excellent
control over the E6 Square H but notbe
plays Rook to d8 as the D file is also a
nice open file and you always want to
put your Rooks on nice open files and
here Maxim should play Rook to E3 uh
Rook to E3 that there are maybe some
moves like Queen to F2 but Rook to E3 is
a very useful move uh for one you gain
more more space uh you can also use it
to attack the black king you also gain
control over the D3 Square because you
know that something will land on D3 at
some point but he doesn't he plays Pawn
to E5 and the reason for this is that he
thought uh well it's not a problem I
mean even if something like Bishop to D3
happens I always have the D F2 Square
for my queen which is a great Square for
the queen but he overlooked one very
very cool tactical idea Notre backck
found and you guys will I'm sure as well
so feel free to pause the video and try
to find this nasty idea that Maxim
missed uh while I give you a couple of
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on uh
finding the real reason for the move and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it is Knight to G4 with check
and it's not just that it works
beautifully tactically the reason why
Knight to G4 is so incredible is that it
takes away the F2 Square from the from
the White Queen not because if you
capture it you're going to lose the game
which we will show uh point is that once
you capture Queen H4 check just picks up
the Rook on E1 and there's really no
counterplay that you can have after King
H2 like even C4 just wins the game on
the spot uh problem is that once you
capture just Queen H4 check King to G1
you will capture on C4 and now if Queen
captures uh you can uh simply win the
back rank Rook to D1 with check the has
no squares you have to move the queen
here then you give up the queen then you
give up the bishop and that's pretty
much it black wins very easily uh so you
can do that another another thing after
Knight to G4 check can you go to G1 yes
you can that's in fact the absolute best
move but the reason why Maxim probably
avoided it is that after King to G1 you
no longer have the F2 Square for the
White Queen because now Bishop to D3
what do you do with the White Queen
that's why Knight to G4 is so impressive
you have to put the queen to D1 in front
of the rook and and okay white black
doesn't have any uh immediate tactical
shots you can do with the bishop because
pretty much everything is on dark
squares and your knight here is now
hanging so you will have to move the
Knight and then some E6 action and okay
the the game continues probably
something like C4 he captures an F7
check Queen capts Bishop A4 goes after
the pawn uh Queen defense and the black
retains a much better position but maybe
just maybe you can still survive this um
although not very likely because it's
notbe who needs only a draw here and
Maxim has to win the game so he played
King to G3 uh but now again the position
is completely winning Rook to D3 with
check the king cannot go back the Knight
controls all of these squares so you
have to either go to H4 uh which you
can't because the queen is guarding that
or you can capture on G4 which is what
Maxim did H5 with check H you have to
capture or you you go to F5 and then
just Rook to D4 you control the E4
square and now G6 will be Checkmate uh
or white just starts giving up pieces
but you know to no avail so after H5
check King captures on H5 was played now
G6 with check King to G4 and Bishop to
C8 with check and he was in this
position un move 28 that notbe abdat won
the game or rather that Maxim vashir lra
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here the king is
completely cut off from the third rank
Queen covers H4 so the only thing you
can do is push the pawn then the bishop
captures then okay you do get the F4
Square for your king but now Queen to H4
with check G4 Queen to H6 with check
only move G5 and now Queen to H4 will be
Checkmate Maxim didn't wait for this
after Bishop to c a check he's he just
resigned with a king on G4 uh but yeah
you've seen how how easily things can go
very very wrong up until this point he
was perfectly fine Rook to d8 by far the
strongest move for notb because you
really need that D3 square and very odd
for maxim with 10 10 and a half minutes
on the clock not playing Rook to E3 uh
very very strange stuff it's a it's a
clear oversight but probably he thought
that uh you know sometimes even I and
other players do this sometimes you
think well if it's not a threat let's
not defend against it because the worst
thing you can do in chess is to defend
against non-existent threats sometimes
your opponent will launch a kingside
attack and you'll be like okay those
pawns are Marching forward maybe I
should SP something like G6 or H6 just
uh have them ready to stop the attack
but no you don't want to play that you
if it's needed you play it if it's not
needed uh then um all you've done is
given your opponent targets the to
attack later on so you know don't don't
be afraid of ghosts in chess probably
that's what happened to Maxim here he
was banking on that Queen to F2 move but
then once Notre backck um uh once Notre
backck put a knight on G4 and took away
df2 Square from the White Queen he
realized okay this is this is not not
the best uh so yeah that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it I would like to
thank Milos kovich trits for Meo David
Kimura Marty Vidal and Robert araton for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World uh thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day